alright the suppression of free speech
is beginning with the Donald Trump
administration we already saw that he
was so triggered by the low inauguration
attendance that he had his press
secretary Sean Spicer go out there and
just straight-up lie to media lies which
were then represented by Kellyanne
Conway his counselor as quote
alternative fact on NBC news that we
talked about earlier but we've also
learned about a suppression of
government speech that took place during
the inauguration the Twitter account for
the National Park Service retweeted a
tweet about the low turnout with
pictures I'll show you a picture of what
that looked like and as you can see here
at the top of the image it says National
Park Service retweeted and this was a
comparison of 2009 inauguration
attendance of 2017 inauguration
attendance later that day the NPS
Twitter account along with all the other
Department of Interior accounts went
totally silent the order reportedly came
from a career staffer at the department
who instructed employees that the new
administration has said that the
department and all bureaus are not
supposed to tweet this weekend and wait
for guidance from Trump until Monday and
the message continued please make sure
that any scheduled tweets are no longer
scheduled this was an order this was not
a request very quickly the retweet about
the inauguration attendance from the
National Park Service was undone and the
following day this tweet was sent take a
look at this we regret the mistaken
retweets from our account yesterday and
look forward to continuing to share the
beauty and history of our parks with you
shouldn't they know by now pat twitter
is only to be used by government
officials when spreading propaganda
about our glorious and fearless orange
leader any tweets that don't express
admiration for the dear leader are to be
stopped or removed immediately it's very
concerning especially considering that
the National Park Service and the
Department of the Interior aren't too
political organizations so if he's doing
this to them you can only imagine what
he's going to do to other departments
foreign governments to this is the
reality under Trump
and what will the people who are
supposed supposedly supposed supporters
of free and open speech say as Twitter
accounts are limited as media outlets
are kicked out of having access to the
president or staffers you would hope
that they would fight back but I assume
the Trump ians will just accept because
hey it is our glorious leader who is
sending out these dictates we're going
to follow it and it is getting ugly
already